Welcome back to human emotion.
So today we're going to talk about the way that emotion shape the way we
actually think.
And here we'll try to answer some of the biggest questions that have plagued,
you know,
scientists,
psychologists,
and even philosophers since the beginning of time where we tried to think about
our emotions truly irrational or can they actually help us think?
And in what ways do they,
so for example,
we'll be answering questions such as can emotion change our thinking?
Can it change the way that we actually remember important life events
and count emotion change how we actually perceive the world,
whether we view it through rosy colored glasses or maybe more for Lauren and
dysphoric glasses.
In other words,
do we see the world,
you know,
more Pollyanna or as some people say more as an er.
So here,
emotion and cognition were once thought to be really completely separate
entities and actually perhaps even in conflict with each other.
And indeed emotions were thought to be completely antithetical or the opposite
of what was thought to be higher order,
rational thinking and cognitive faculties recently,
however,
a studies and emotion,
I found that this is absolutely not the case.
And in fact,
emotion and cognition actually overlap and really fascinating and intricate
ways.
So what we're going to study today is a little bit of the ways in which emotion
and cognition may mutually shape each other and actually change the way that you
think about the world merely by changing your current emotional state.
So this is our first part of a three part series on emotion and cognition.
So in our,
in our introduction today we're going to take a broad view to answer the
question of do feelings actually shape the way we think?
And let me walk you through a roadmap of how we're going to do this today.
We'll start by looking at the relationship between emotion and memory,
followed by processing style judgment.
And then we'll conclude with our typical takeaway questions and expert
interview.
So today we'll start with looking at how emotion shapes the way we remember the
world around us.
And William James First had the initial,
very prescient observation that indeed emotions must somehow influenced the way
we remember the world around us.
He said an impression may be so emotionally exciting as to leave a scar upon our
cerebral tissues.
So he indeed thought that emotions are so powerful that they'll leave this
almost indelible mark upon our brain.
And the way we remember the world around us.
Since William James,
there's been questions that have really tried to more specifically look at the
way in which emotions shape memories.
In other words,
do they make these mental marks upon us that are permanent and not,
cannot be altered or even maybe mutated time.
So the first question we'll look at today is whether or not emotional memories
indeed are indelible.
So the original work here,
um,
started in the 70s with this concept of flashbulb memories.
So flashbulb memories are really like what you might think of a flashbulb sort
of instant photograph of any event.
So this is the phenomena whereby emotional memories are often recalled more
vividly after an event and they're extra recall called an almost this kind of
photographic form where you can know where you were,
what was going on at the time,
who told you the news at the time,
how others felt.
Um,
you may be how you felt and sort of what happened next.
So almost what emotions do is they sort of flash this light over what events are
going on in the world around you so that you can store them in your mind almost
like a still frame or movie that you can play chronologically over time.
So this is the idea of flashbulb memories that emotions really create this
almost permanent indelible mark upon your memory.
Okay.
One example that's often talked about with flashbulb memories,
um,
and that many people in the u s can remember is the terrorist attacks of nine
11.
So many people will say they can remember where they were,
what they were doing,
what they were thinking when this happened.
Um,
and this notion was also confirmed in the former President Bush has televised
address to Congress in September where he said,
each of us will remember what happened that day and to whom it happened.
We remember the moment the news came where we were and what we were doing.
Now,
some researchers have actually argued against this idea that flashbulb memories
exist.
And if we see here in this study here where they say confidence,
not consistency,
characterize this flashbulb memories,
we peek at what they wrote,
they would actually suggest that flashbulb memories are not special in their
accuracy as previously claimed,
but only in their perceived accuracy.
Right?
So what they did is they really questioned whether or not flashbulb memories
actually exist.
And they did this by comparing memories of one the memory of the nine 11
terrorist attacks with a second memory of just some normal everyday event to see
whether or not really emotionally sailing events actually indeed do leave these
indelible marks upon our,
on our memory.
And here's what they found.
So they found some differences that you can see at the top left.
So the differences are that people believe that fat flashbulb memories such as
those of nine 11 are more accurately and vividly remembered and the intensity of
emotions experienced during these events are related to people's greater
confidence in their accuracy.
So the more that we feel we had an intense emotion experience,
the more confident we feel and see in thinking that these are indeed more vivid
memories on our mind.
However,
there were actually no differences and whether or not nine 11 was more likely to
be remembered some everyday event.
Right.
And in fact what might be the case is that the memory for these kinds of
emotionally salient traumatic life events actually seems to decline at a similar
rate over time for other more every day neutral or non emotional information.
So some may argue that flashbulb memories such as those like nine 11 are only
enduring because they'd be become reinforced by the media.
We've seen multiple repetitions of them time and time again online in the news,
speaking to people in conversations.
But the actual memory itself of when that happened in our own personal lives is
no more memorable than any other everyday event.
Yeah.
So interestingly here,
um,
this is another idea that's looking at a distortion and memory for emotions.
And here what they found is [inaudible] question of is there a memory for
emotions themselves?
Right?
So do we have an enhanced memory for emotional events?
So the method that they did in this study is that they had students write their
anxiety level before midterm and then they recalled their anxiety level
approximately one week later before or after learning our grade.
And the results suggest that compared to students who hadn't yet learned their
grade,
those who did learn that they did well or learn that they did well on the test
underestimated their pretest anxiety.
Whereas students who did poorly overestimated their pretests anxiety.
So this merely suggest when we think about emotions and memory,
that information learned after the fact actually distorts your memory for the
original emotions themselves.
So when we come to this first question,
our emotional memories,
indelible,
not necessarily,
perhaps emotions don't really sort of seal memory in some special way.
But what about the second question here of do emotion states actually improve
memory at all?
So let's look at the second question.
So even if emotion memories aren't indelible,
do they play some role in helping to facilitate or influence our memories?
Okay,
so this is work by Gordon Bauer.
So Gordon power,
like a really push this idea forward of emotion congruent and hear what he did
is he argued that emotions are part of these associative networks in our mind
and that each emotion has what he called inner connected images,
concepts,
labels and interpretations.
And what happens is that when you experience an emotion,
so thinking of it as a node in the middle of a network,
that these associations get activated almost like if you think of an octopus and
the center of the octopus and it spreads out with eight branching legs.
When that emotion gets activated,
you see these associations that sort of merge or sort of spire out,
they get activated.
So for an example,
when you're in a happy mood,
you're better able to remember associated happy memories or happy related
information.
And here's some evidence for emotion concurrence.
So he found that people are able to better remember information if they learn it
and recall it in the same congruent emotional state.
So if you learn something while you're in a fearful state,
you're better able to recall that information later on if you're also in an
anxious or fearful state than if you're in a happy state leader on,
okay.
And here's some evidence that he found.
So if you look at this graph carefully,
what you find is he looked at people who are induced into either a happy mood in
yellow or a sad mood in blue.
And what he did is he asked people to recall a number of either pleasant or
unpleasant related memories,
but they had before the age of 15 that you can see here on the bottom.
And what you're seeing in this graph is that in the happy mood.
So if we follow the line in yellow,
what we see is that people in a happy mood recall significantly more pleasant
memories before they were 15.
By contrast,
people in a sad mood recall slightly more unpleasant memories than pleasant
memories.
So it suggests that our mood states give us some special access to information
that is consistent with whatever state we're in.
If we're happy,
we can recall more positive information.
If we're sad,
we can recall more negative information.
Okay.
So he further pushed this idea of emotion concurrence in another study.
So the method in this study,
he had subjects read a story about two guys who were playing tennis.
Um,
and here's how it went.
So Andre was playing tennis and he was happy.
All is going well for him,
whereas Jack is sad,
nothing's going well for him.
So then they were asked to recall the story and ask them the participants,
who do you think is the central character?
So the results suggested that happy readers remembered more statements about
Andre the happy character and actually thought the story was about him,
whereas sad readers remember more statements about the sad character.
Jack and thought the story was about him.
Hm.
So there's some important caveats to keep in mind with emotion concurrence.
Um,
here,
I mean,
this was really Gordon Bauer and the fields first serious attempt to try to
integrate emotion in models of learning and memory.
So as a first attempt,
there's always caveats,
right?
So first,
you know,
we see emotion congruency and the graph we saw with the yellow and blue lines,
that seems to be stronger for positive than negative emotional information.
And sometimes mood incongruent information can be better recalled.
So,
well,
it's an interesting theory.
There's still some caveats that needs to be worked out as future research moves
forward.
Okay.
So our emotion memories indelible,
not necessarily,
but do emotions enhance memory at all?
Well,
I would say why,
yes,
it seems that they do,
but there's still some interesting caveats as to the role,
um,
where we understand precisely how they do it.
So we've talked a little bit about emotion and memory.
And what I want to do now is move into this concept of processing style.
And here we're looking to look at the ways in which different kinds of mood
states,
positive or negative shaped the way that we process information just in the
world around us.
So now we're going to turn to processing style.
So here I want to show you a table and what I want to walk through or some core
differences between the ways positive emotions and negative emotions shaped the
way that we process information.
So first what we see here is that positive emotions really facilitate the use of
what are called heuristics or mental shortcuts and they actually cause us to
engage in more stereotype related thinking.
So in other words,
positive emotions really kind of move us through these kind of information
related processes by just taking more quick mental shortcuts.
Whereas negative emotions seem to almost slow us down in some ways and
facilitate more careful,
more analytical,
more detail oriented types of thinking.
As a result,
you can see positive emotions.
What they do is they really seem to promote this kind of broader kind of
creative thinking.
You're sort of focus less on the details of a particular,
uh,
situation that you're in and you're really kind of expanding and broadening,
broadening your cognitive repertoire,
right?
Whereas again,
negative emotions,
it's more analytical thought and promotes really more kind of detail oriented
concrete thinking.
So they each are seeming to serve really different types of cognitive functions.
Um,
not surprisingly positive emotions or thought to facilitate what's called a
global focus.
They kind of keep us focused on,
you can think of it as the forest,
whereas negative emotions are really about honing in and focusing on the trees.
Um,
not surprising that there's been some empirical work,
um,
by Barb Fredrickson and colleagues that,
you know,
positive emotions really do seem to support this broader focus of attention.
Whereas by contrast,
negative emotions are promoting narrowed attention and focus really on the
situational details.
So the way I like to think about it as I think of negative emotions is almost
putting on these blinders and getting new,
really zeroed in on a very concrete task right in front of you.
So imagine if there was a bear in front of yours,
snake.
You don't want to be sort of paying attention to the landscape as a whole and
engaging in creative thinking.
You want to focus in narrowly on how you're going to either fight or flee that
given dangerous Q be at a snake bear,
et cetera.
Whereas positive emotions really signaled to us that we're in a place of safety.
So we can kind of take a step back.
We can broaden our attentional scope,
we can gauge and creative thinking and we don't necessarily need to take the
kind of,
you know,
careful analytical steps that are involved in,
we're in a more negative emotional situation or environment.
So these are different types of processing styles that are associated with
positive and negative emotions.
Um,
the one caveat you can see here on the bottom corner is that says quote,
you know,
asterisk except anger.
So anger is then this really interesting,
mysterious emotion because on the one hand,
we all think of it as being negatively balanced.
But on the other hand would,
it actually does is it shares a lot of the same processing style features of
positive emotions.
So it's a really exciting mystery in the field,
um,
that we'll definitely talk about later in the course.
Um,
but when we think about sort of what kind of state do you want to be in,
if you're really trying to think carefully and get things right,
there's a lot of controversy on this,
right?
So on the one hand you can imagine people who are engaged in sort of artistic
endeavors,
writers,
musicians,
poets saying that positive emotions are really what you need to sort of get
ahead in your creative cognitive endeavors.
Whereas others might say with negative emotions that you really want to be in
maybe a bad mood.
So this is an article it as be sad and succeed people in a bad mood have better
judgment and pay more attention to details.
Um,
so I think for yourself for a moment,
you know,
what kind of mood states have you been in when you've been able to think the
most clearly and achieve the goals that you are most interested in working on.
Um,
so I recommend you looking at some of the work here,
Joe,
for guests.
He's at the University of New South Wales.
If you're interested in further exploring this topic.
Okay.
Um,
and here as you can say,
ah,
it says grumpy,
people pay closer attention to details,
showed less scalability.
We're less prone to errors of judgment and formed higher quality persuasive
arguments,
then they're happy counterparts.
One study even supports the notion that those who showed either signs of fear,
anger,
or sadness,
um,
also seem to do better.
And I witnessed recall studies.
So again,
take a look if you're interested in learning more about this,
of the way in which being sad may actually help you think more carefully and
more closely.
Yeah.
So another way in which we look at how,
um,
you know,
emotions shape our processing style.
The world is by looking at patterns of attentional bias or the ways in which we
literally view the world and what ways emotions may actually shaped the lenses
through which we see the world.
So here researchers looking at attention related by a CS will ask questions.
I'm like,
if people are in a positive mood,
do they have what's called a positive attentional bias?
Are they more prone to visually orient and pay attention to cues in the
environment that are positive or rewarding?
Likewise,
there's been work,
especially in anxiety and depression showing that people in these negative mood
states show and enhance negative attentional bias.
They actually spend more time looking at negative emotional information if you
present them with different types of images,
of emotional faces,
some of the I ops photos we talked about earlier in course,
et cetera.
So emotions also seem to shape the lens through which we view the world.
And there's a couple of different paradigms that people use to test this all
briefly walk you through.
Now.
Um,
one of them is called,
uh,
at edit.
Then one of them is called an eye tracking tasks.
So I tracking tasks are really interesting in is what they enable you to do is
look at attention related biases.
So using eye tracking technology,
you can actually unobtrusively and continuously monitor an individual's point of
gaze using an infrared light beam by looking at their eyes are orienting on a
computer screen while they're viewing standardized positive,
negative,
or even neutral,
um,
picture stimuli,
word stimulate,
et cetera.
And another type of very popular paradigm here is what's called dot probe tasks.
So dot.
Protests are also very helpful and that they enable you to more directly assess
potential biases in patterns of attentional distribution,
often showing simultaneous images on a screen such as a sad and happy face,
and looking at where people attend to and respond to first.
So importantly,
when we think about a positive emotion and cognition,
it's vitally important to know Barbara Fredrickson's broaden and build theory of
positive emotions.
So her theory suggests that positive emotions exist to build an individual's
resources necessary for survival,
and she would say they do so by broadening one's thought processes and creating
a wider than normal array of thoughts,
behaviors,
and perceptions.
And this cognitive broadening actually results in more creative,
integrative and future oriented and efficient thinking.
And she would say this facilitates the discovery of new knowledges and builds
vital social and cognitive resources.
So the broaden and build theory has been monumental.
And really explaining links between the ways that positive emotion can influence
directly creative thinking and efficient thinking.
So this is something that's in your readings and I suggest reading further as we
think about the ways in which positive emotions specifically can affect our
cognitive processes.
So what I want to conclude now with is the ways in which emotions influence
judgements or everyday types of decisions.
Here.
One of the most influential theories is by doctor Gerald core at the University
of Virginia who really put forward his theory that's been absolutely pioneering
in this domain called aspect of information.
And really what it stipulates is that emotions are informative.
They give us information when we're making important judgments.
Um,
so we need to pay attention to them as cues of information in order to make
everyday choices and decisions.
Why might emotions be so important in this way?
Well first,
he would argue that they provide us with a quick rapid signal about our
environment.
And second,
many judgments in everyday life are often too complex to take in all
information.
So we often have to be quicker and rely on a more simple assessment of our
current feelings in order to make quick judgments in the moment.
So in other words,
emotions can sort of serve as heuristics for us.
And he did a really landmark study here when he was really piloting,
uh,
or pioneering.
His affect is as information theory is follows.
So he had a study that went as follows.
So in the first condition that you see on the left,
he asks people,
I'm calling them on a day that was either cloudy or sunny,
and asking them all things considered,
how satisfied are you with your life as a whole these days?
And in the second condition,
he first asked them,
well,
how's the weather today?
Is it sunny?
Is it cloudy and rainy?
And then he asks them the same question,
how satisfied are you with your life as a whole these days?
What he found is that,
um,
people,
and this is what he predicted.
It's really interesting that those who had not been asked about the weather and
condition one would use their current feelings as information to make complex
judgments such as how satisfied they are with their life as a whole.
Whereas those in condition two who were first asked about the weather,
he reasoned would no longer use their feelings and making these complex
judgments.
So in sum,
what he found is that people use emotions as these heuristics or shortcuts and
making judgments except when they attribute their feelings to a certain source
such as the weather.
So not surprisingly,
you find that people in this condition or reporting feeling more satisfied with
their life as a whole and the weather is sunny as opposed to cloudy,
but you see this effect sort of mitigate once they can attribute it to the
weather and you'd no longer see as pronounced,
have an effect on ratings of life satisfaction.
Um,
and here you can see this as some of the data that came from it that we just
talked about where again,
what we're seeing in condition one that people are rating higher life
satisfaction when the weather's sunny in white as compared to when it's overcast
and gray.
But that once you sort of cue them in to attributing their emotions to the
weather,
you no longer see differences in life satisfaction,
um,
as a result of the weather.
So again,
people are using emotions as heuristics or shortcuts and making judgments except
when they can attribute their feelings to a specific source.
So again,
this is a really remarkable finding and let me just emphasize why.
So this perspective,
so he says that what we are doing is using what we're feeling in the moment and
attributing our feelings to some other source,
right?
And if our attention is drawn to something else that may be influencing our
feelings,
like the weather,
we no longer use our feelings as information to help make judgments and really
big judgments such as how satisfied are we with our life as a whole.
So it's a powerful effect.
It's been replicated in many labs and in fact,
feelings do seem to influence our judgments until we attach those feelings to
other things.
So what I want to do now is conclude with our takeaway questions and our expert
interview.
So for our takeaway questions today,
this was our first introduction into the realm of emotion and cognition.
The first question really starts at the beginning of our lecture asking what are
flashbulb memories and is there supportive empirical evidence to what is the
broaden and build theory of positive emotion positive by Barbara Fredrickson?
And how does it explain the effect of positive emotion on cognition?
And importantly,
I want you to also think about the different processing styles we spoke about
that compare the way positive emotion affects cognition as compared to negative
emotion.
Finally,
what is the aspect is information theory that we just spoke about,
um,
put forth by Gerald core.
And how does it,
the ways in which emotion might influence every day judgments such as how
satisfied are you feeling with your life as a whole today?
Now we'll turn to our expert interview and this is part of the experts in
emotion interview series.
Today we'll be speaking with doctor Gerald core on emotion and cognition.
Dr Core is a Commonwealth professor of psychology at the University of Virginia
and formerly an alumni distinguished professor at the University of Illinois.
His research focuses on emotion and it's cognitive consequences.
He's coauthored the cognitive structure of emotions,
a general theory of how psychological situations elicit emotions and make them
intense.
It's chief application is in computer science as the emotion engine of
intelligent agents and robots,
computer games and interactive training modules.
His research has been funded by both the NIH and NSF and concerns.
The effect is information hypothesis,
which clarifies how emotional information about value and urgency help to shape
or regulate cognition,
motivation,
and even memory.
Dr Clore has served as an associate editor of cognition and emotion as faculty
in the Nih consortium on emotion and as a visiting professor at Harvard
University.
He's also been a visiting scholar at Harvard,
Oxford and New York University and a fellow of the Centers for advanced study,
Illinois,
Stanford,
and the Rockefeller Center in Italy.
In 2010 he was elected to the American Academy of Arts and Sciences.
And in 2013 he received the William James Award for scientific achievement from
the association for Psychological Science.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview with doctor Gerald
core.